[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the smartphone awards 2017.
so the way we do it here i mean there
were a lot of phones released over the
course of this year from different
manufacturers in different styles in
different price ranges with different
features all kinds of stuff like that so
this show is the best way to figure out
the best of the best of what's come out
in the last 12 months so the way we do
it here is i'm going to declare in each
category a winner and then also if there
are some other good ones i can declare a
second place sort of a runner-up which
is also really good in that category and
then maybe some honorable mentions every
single phone on this desk was released
during 2017 that's actually that hasn't
always been true about this show but
that's true this year you can check me
on that so there's a lot to choose from
so uh let's get started so category
number one is best big phone so phones
keep getting bigger every year there's
almost no way around that even with the
shrinking bezels and i'm a big phone
person not gonna lie there's a regular
version and a plus version of a phone
i'm taking the plus i'm taking the xl or
the bigger one and so these are gonna be
the best phones that take the most
advantage of having a large amount of
space so big display big battery
big features etc and the winner for that
category for 2017 is going to be
the samsung
galaxy note 8.
[Music]
the note 8 does it all and it's been a
kind of a staple big phone for a while
in their lineup the biggest reason i
usually want a big phone is for a big
screen note 8 has that it's the best
display on any phone it has a pretty big
battery it has big optically stabilized
dual cameras it has a big stylus for
those who are into that big specs and of
course big software features to take
advantage of being such a large phone i
still remember when the first galaxy
note came out like the first two were
such a staple in like the tech on
youtube community because that was like
the phone that had everything you would
take that phone to ces because it had
the longest battery life and a
replaceable battery this is still that
slight step above galaxy s8 in their
lineup it kind of always will be that
way and holds a special place in my
heart for that reason but there is a
runner-up and that came from actually a
pretty new player in the space i mean
it's as new as you can get they exist in
the space for the first time this year
and they happen to do a really good job
of taking advantage of so much space in
a phone
and that's the razer phone the razer
phone is an awesome use of being big in
a world of these super thin bezels this
phone is bigger than normal and
shamelessly so it keeps the huge bezels
and inside them it fits these huge
speakers which are pretty much best in
class and it also happens to have a huge
4000 milliamp hour battery it doesn't
have quite as many you know big screen
features as say a samsung phone it
doesn't have as much split screen
multitasking fun it doesn't have a
stylus and all that stuff but it's just
a good use of space in the hardware
department for being such a big phone i
really like it so the next category is
best compact phone
and this is a rare breed not gonna lie
like the compact flagship smartphone is
much less popular just because phones
are still getting that much bigger so
the definition of a compact phone has
changed in size especially but for me
the definition is still going to be one
that keeps as many flagship features as
possible in a small package
and so for that reason the winner of
this category is
iphone 8
[Music]
iphone 8 is a legit flagship to a lot of
people it has all the highest end specs
and almost every single feature of the
iphone 8 plus except for the dual
cameras and it's in the smallest package
so it's easily the most compact if
you're a small hands person you want the
lightest smallest device possible iphone
8 is going to do that for you it kind of
got overshadowed by the slightly bigger
iphone 10 and even bigger iphone 8 plus
but if you're looking for obviously a
great camera a pretty solid ips display
if you're still into the fingerprint
reader on the front touch id is still
extremely fast i mean this thing is
complete so that's getting the best
compact smartphone but if you're looking
for a runner up in that category i think
it's a no-brainer to give that to a
slightly bigger phone but still one that
keeps all the flagship features of its
big brother and that would be the pixel
2. if your biggest complaint is that you
don't get the better camera of the
iphone 8 plus on the iphone 8 pixel 2
has the exact same camera as pixel 2 xl
it's a little bit boxier and has a
little bit bigger bezels but you still
get front-facing speakers you still get
a great display and you still get all
the same specs and features as you do on
the bigger phone so this is another
smaller version of a phone that does all
the same things as its bigger brother it
might even have a better screen than the
xl also another honorable mention shout
out to the galaxy s8 for being by far
the best designed compact phone the s8
plus is its bigger brother but you still
get the infinity display and of course
all the same specs as the s8 plus in
this smaller phone so again if you're
into smaller phones all the features of
the bigger brother will come from those
so the next category is best
camera this was a good one this year
obviously everyone here on this desk has
a camera on the back and most people
take most of the photos in their life
with their smartphone camera
and the winner for this year this
category actually took such good photos
and videos that it spoiled me to the
point where i didn't want to use some
other phones this year because the
cameras just didn't stack up it was that
good they've always been good but this
year was particularly great the winner
for best camera in a smartphone
is google pixel 2.
[Music]
this was a pretty easy one for me the
photos and videos from this guy but
particularly the photos are ridiculous
from pixel 2 and pixel 2 xl awesome
detail dynamic range
sharpness
fast focus image stabilization low light
performance
it's pretty much great at everything and
it's just super easy to use and on top
of all that the portrait mode is
incredible with one camera so again it
does the same thing in the pixel 2 and 2
xl i'm going to link all the reviews of
all the phones i talk about in the
description below that like button so if
you want to see all the sample photos
and hear me rave in detail about each
one then you can check that out but for
now just know that pixel 2 takes the
best photos you can get on a smartphone
my runner-up is one that i think
actually does better video just because
240 frames per second slow motion high
quality 1080p video is severely
underrated and that comes from the dual
optically image stabilized camera
wielding
iphone x not a lot of cameras are
capable of what this thing is in the
video department and it fits in your
pocket which is awesome but i think most
importantly despite its exposure
problems iphone 10 photos have the best
colors like if i could combine the pixel
2's image processing and dynamic range
and portrait mode and sharpness and
detail and all that with the iphone's
colors
i totally would so the next one is best
budget phone so this is going to be the
one that gives you the most smartphone
for the least amount of money that's
what it's all about you can ask people
everyone has a different definition of
budget if you say what's the best cheap
phone cheap means something different to
everyone but either way you look at it
this winner has the best smartphone bang
for the buck the most phone for the
least money and that one is
the oneplus 5t
[Music]
that's because for the price this thing
really is a flagship from the design the
all-metal build the thin bezels the dual
cameras the high-end specs eight gigs of
ram uh it's not skimping anywhere it
even keeps the headphone jack but in a
year where we've seen phones costing
seven eight nine hundred even a thousand
bucks the oneplus 5t does almost
everything they all do and it starts at
499 bucks that is serious bang for the
buck and that's why it wins the award
this year now a lot of people might be
thinking wait a second 500 bucks isn't
quite what i would consider budget and i
agree again cheap is different for
everyone so i'll give my runner-up to
moto g5 plus which is still the best
phone you could get under 300 bucks in
fact it's probably closer to 200 bucks
now we reviewed it so long ago earlier
this year but it's still the best bang
for the buck under that price range and
also give an honorable mention to huawei
honor 7x all these phones are doing
great things for the money and i'll
repeat what i have said before good
phones
are getting cheap well not so much we
still get thousand dollar flagships but
cheap phones are getting really good so
the next category is best battery life
this one's pretty simple right we just
look for the ones that have the longest
lasting battery that will last an entire
day us heavy users look for long screen
on time and we look for being able to
take it off the charger early in the
morning and not touch it again until
late that night with no issues and the
winner for that category has been
the razer phone
[Music]
so another award for the newcomer in
2017 razer phone made a great use of
that space that big chassis and that
huge inside they put a 4 000 milliamp
hour battery in here and it showed it
lasts a really long time they built this
phone around gaming so a lot of their
decisions were around gaming eight gigs
of ram because it'll make gaming better
big speakers because it'll make gaming
better huge battery because gaming is
really battery intensive but a lot of
those things just make a better phone so
if you're not gaming all the time razer
phones still has a huge battery which
means it lasts almost forever so that's
why i won the award this year i'll leave
the full review link below if you want
to check that out but i'll also give
some runner-ups or sort of an honorable
mention to two phones that lasted a
really long time one is pixel 2 xl the
oled display stock android and huge
battery did great for it lasted all day
for me pretty much every time
and also my iphone 8 plus is still the
king of standby time it's a huge battery
and a smaller display because of those
big old bezels but that just means it
lasts you all day and if you use an
iphone you kind of know already this
thing is really good so this next
category is
my design award and this is one that's
actually kind of evolved over the years
because it used to just be the one that
had the craziest design it used to be
the best built phone this year in 2017
it's going to be the one that i think
has the best combo of design and build
and that's going to go to another
newcomer for this year
and it's the essential phone
[Music]
this was one of my favorite and most
polarizing phones of the year i really
couldn't recommend it because when it
first came out it fell short and a
couple other categories like the camera
and battery life for the price they were
trying to charge but now that they've
dropped the price so much i really think
this is one of the best looking phones
to come out and it's worth the price
again it's a ceramic back titanium sides
and there's all different ways to handle
super thin bezels but this notch really
drew on me and when you actually look
back at using the phone i got used to it
really quick i liked it a lot and i
think overall this one's the design
award so now that i've ruffled your
feathers with the notch i do have some
runner ups also and i'm gonna give that
to the iphone 10 again for getting rid
of the home button the iphone had huge
forehead and chin bezels for so long
that even if there is a notch i again
got used to it really quickly and i
think getting rid of the home button was
a major step for it so that gets the
runner-up award and i'll also give it to
galaxy s8 and s8 plus the super clean
design from the review you've already
seen but the overhanging glass on each
side it's not everybody's favorite
because of the curved edges and some
potential accidental screen touches but
i think it's super clean and it's hard
to argue with just how good it looks
being this this glass sandwich and this
super sleek design so that's my design
award so this next award is for the
biggest
bust of the year
there's a bust every year i hate giving
out this award because you want to be
positive and you want to focus on the
best of the best because there's so much
good
but some just stick out like a sore
thumb and and just are not a good use of
space for some particular reason so
the bust of the year for 2017 as you
probably saw coming is the htc u ultra
[Music]
yeah no this this one takes the cake
worst phone of the year for 2017 just
not a lot good to say about this one i
don't want to spend a ton of time on it
if you watch the review on it or if
you've seen the title you know exactly
how i feel so i don't want to spend a
ton of time on that but if we move on
quickly to the next award to chill out
the htc elevate comments section uh this
is the biggest comeback of the year it's
the most improved player it's just
sometimes you have to fall down hard to
take your next biggest step up and i
think that's exactly what htc did this
year because then htc u11 came out and
it turned out to be great
[Music]
yeah this thing had a lot more going for
it it has obviously the sweet color
changing back which i'm a big fan of but
just generally was a really good phone
had a much better camera it didn't add a
headphone jack but it had speakers had a
really nice display and a nice software
experience from htc and these phones
would also introduce us to that squeeze
feature with the pressure sensitive
sides to launch something that we would
later see in the pixel 2 and 2xl so that
was really cool to see and then even
later in this year htc came out with the
htc u11 plus which i don't have because
it never came to the us but that was an
even more complete more impressive phone
that thing had an even better camera it
had an even better design with the
see-through back that i think looked
really cool so yeah htc's year kind of
went something like that but then had a
thing like that they kind of had come
back player of the year written on their
forehead from the beginning and so that
brings us to the mvp the finale the best
phone of the year to come out in 2017.
and there i mean there can only be one
but there were so many great phones that
came out over the past 365 days you know
pixel 2 had its highlights lg v30
probably the most underrated we had
oneplus 5t doing big things for low
prices even huawei mate 10 pro flying
under the radar iphone 10 making waves
so many big new phone names coming out
razer phone essential phones stuff we
didn't expect to see
but there's only one mvp there's only
one most complete phone of the year
and my winner for that
is the samsung galaxy note 8.
[Music]
this is actually the most complete
smartphone that came out this year
honestly the biggest problem i have with
this design i know there's a lot of
glass phones out right now is the
placement of the fingerprint reader and
that is a nitpick for a lot of people
everything else about this it's
waterproof it keeps the headphone jack
it has a stylus it has a huge battery it
has great software experience it has the
best screen on any phone it has dual
cameras both optically image stabilized
it has big specs lots of ram fast
processor loud cameras expandable
storage did i mention this water
resistant already i mean this thing is
super complete it is expensive and i
think a lot of people have trouble
spending a thousand dollars on a phone
but if you were to you would want it to
be as complete as the note 8 so i
actually don't have a problem with its
price this probably could have also
technically won comeback player of the
year considering what happened to the
galaxy note 7 which was
bust of the year for exploding in
everyone's pockets with the bezels this
thin and the overall design it's kind of
what a lot of people are looking up to
again if samsung could move that
fingerprint reader down a little bit i'd
be really happy but galaxy note 8 is the
mvp and have some runner ups too my
first runner-up for mvp is gonna be the
pixel 2 xl this phone again also has a
lot going for it it has the best camera
in any phone in my experience it has the
best software and the fastest updates of
course already to android 8.1
the fingerprint reader is in the right
place
it doesn't have the headphone jack but
it has great front-facing speakers
the display on the xl is probably the
only one that really kept it holding
back but this is the phone that i have
used for the longest time this year that
my sim card has been in as my daily
driver for a couple of months i keep
coming back to it so that's why i give
the first runner up to the pixel 2. and
then my honorable mention is going to go
to iphone 10 just for finally shifting
what it means to be an iphone because
honestly being an iphone in my mind
before this thing came out meant not
having modern design and not having thin
bezels on the top of the bottom and this
changes that this has a modern design
and thin bezels now it's also paved the
way for a bunch of other thousand dollar
phones to come out now that this is so
damn expensive uh but i like that it's
paved the way for future iphones to also
be modern and clean and admirable in the
design department the way they haven't
been so that's a good start so that's it
that's the best of what's come out this
year in 2017 not a bad year if you ask
me as far as what came out uh and
whether you're a person that has you
know a preference for low budget phones
or if you like big phones or compact
phones or if you need an all-day battery
whatever you're into whatever you need
from a smartphone you can probably get
it and you'd be hard-pressed going wrong
with something on this table right now
smartphone cameras got so good that i
just i'm more encouraged than ever to
take photos with my pixel 2 the display
has got so amazing galaxy note 8 looks
like a freaking movie theater if you're
looking at it in the dark like there's
so many good things to focus on uh that
it's just fun to look back at the stuff
that came out over the year and that's
part of why this series is so fun but
yeah that's pretty much it if you got
someone you know that's looking to buy a
phone around this holiday season should
probably send in this video
but until then until the next one thank
you for watching
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]
you